Her low freak bitches. It's like, cause
I, I promote a lot of things, you know,
we might disagree on but you know,
I promote a lot of ideas in science
that I've seen the evidence for and I've
seen a lot of it and we disagree.
Um,
you know some dietary things I would
guess like, cause you know, we can,
we can put a hash them like what are,
I don't know.
What are your thoughts on Gmos?
I think genetically modified foods is
apparently almost everything that you buy
at the supermarket. Okay. What did
we agree on that then? Probably,
and it's like I think they
know you by every orange.
If you look at a piece of corn,
oh it's organic.
That Shit is genetically modified.
It's been modified for a hundred years.
You're going to make me cry.
Tears of good Kevin full time before I
was so happy I had him on because he's
never in California.
Brought a, he, we went up,
we don't end up for dinner that night.
So he takes a lot of shit because Monsanto
has funded some of the studies that
they've done. But the studies
are real and the studies of,
I mean you can see the results. They're
not manipulated. Yeah. Kevin, it's,
well actually you know what,
they funded his communication programs
so the heat can come out and do things
like this and they never
funded any of his research.
I misspoke and said, no, no it's fine.
It's uh, but you know what, here's a,
and this is what, where he
got a lot of shit was, um,
was that he said I have nothing
to do with Monsanto. Um,
and like I think if he just said,
you know what,
they fund my communication program but
they don't have anything to do with my
research. Nobody would have a, I think
people still would have been mad,
but I think people would
have been far less mad.
And I feel so bad that he went through
everything with that because there was no,
it's tricky. I mean I just took a tour
there and I got hate mail and it's,
I mean we were so careful cause I was out
there for other business and they were
like, oh you're going to be out in
Ma in Missouri, come have a tour.
Like they didn't pay and I had so
much fun like it was, there was,
they have a lot of really cool tech
there and if you were ever in the area
they'd gladly, I show you around so
they're there. They were nice to me.
I was funny.
One of the,
one of the rumors that I heard about
that was that they only have organic food
in the cafeteria. I'm like, I'm taking,
I'm taking my camera around and taking
pictures of everything. The word organic,
what's organic and
organic uses pesticides and that's
something I think people see it. Yeah,
absolutely. I mean I thought that
was the whole point of organic.
You don't use pesticides.
No.
I'm sure there are some organic
farmers that don't use any possible.
What defines organic food?
Let's find out what is the accepted
definitions of organic food?
Do you want to hear it from me? And then
from, from Google to see if I'm accurate.
All right.
So organic food works by certain farming
stand or agricultural standards and
they can use certain pesticides.
In most cases these pesticides
are derived from natural sources.
I'm not always,
but most of the time and some of these
pesticides includes pesticides like
rotenone and the pirate thrums and also
have, if you're familiar with bt corn,
the bt toxin is also used
in organic farming for the,
because it's a naturally
occurring a toxin,
it can be used and sprayed
topically on organic produce.
So a lot of these,
uh,
the things that we think of as just
conventional farming practices definitely
use an organic farming. It doesn't make
it any better or worse. Um, it just,
in a lot of cases it's a little
more expensive parcel because of the
certification process and partially
because it uses older farming techniques
that need, you know, a little
more land, that type of stuff.
It also uses till farming practices that,
you know,
digs up the ground a bit more and can
release a little more CO2. So in general,
I tend to, Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Simply stated,
organic produce or other ingredients
are grown without the use of pesticides.
Synthetic fertilizers, excuse
me, hold on. Sewage sludge,
genetically modified organisms
or ionizing radiation.
Animals that produce meat,
poultry,
eggs and dairy products do not take
antibiotics or growth hormones.
The U s hold on,
sorry.
The U S Da National Organic
program defines organic as follows.
Organic food is produced by farmers who
emphasize the use of renewable resources
and the conservation of soil and water
to enhance environmental quality for
future generations.
Organic meat,
poultry and eggs and dairy products
are made from animals that are given no
antibiotics or growth hormones.
Organic food is produced without
using most conventional pesticides.
Fertilizers made with
synthetic ingredients or sewage
sludge bioengineering or
ionizing radiation before a product
can be labeled organic and quotes a
government approved certifier and specs
the farm where the food is grown to make
sure the farmers following all the
rules necessary to meet Usda organic
standards.
It's
now the one thing on there that will
disagree with what their first paragraph,
as I say, without the use of
pesticides. In the second paragraph, uh,
it says organic food is
produced without using
most conventional pesticides.
You see that slight little slight of hand
because one of them is theirs and the
other one is Usda.
Exact little slight of hand.
I mean, uh, if you, if, if I may ask,
would you, would you like
to Google? Hold on a second.
Let's Google what pesticides can
be used and still make it organic.
Exactly what I was going to request.
It's a organic pesticides approved
for use in the u s here we go.
Now what are the fears of pesticides?
Right.
People worried about toxins
getting into their food,
getting them their body and cancer.
I mean
I understand that fear partially
cause I went through it quite a bit.
Like when I got sick a few years ago,
like my first symptom wasn't celiac
disease. It wasn't my joints popping out.
I got the worst headache of my life one
day and it never went away like that.
That'll make you scared to
death of everything around
you. Like I went organic,
I went Vegan, I went, I'd cut everything
out of my diet cause I was a scared that,
you know, like you get, you feel like
you're getting stabbed in the eye,
constantly going to cut
everything out of your diet.
One day were said and
I was working and um,
at the time I wasn't working
in the pesticide lab yet.
I was working at a drug analysis lab.
What was going on?
Absorbs. Well, it was, I was um, the
thing that I was worried because I was,
at the time I was all those, there was
much more siloed than the rows here.
So day I was, there was much more of
me and there is here today I was, I'm,
I'm five, nine and I had at the
time weighed almost 250 pounds. I,
I needed to lose a little of
me, but it was like, all right,
I'm eating shitty food. I should probably
try eating healthier. But I mean,
nevermind just more salads. I'm
like, I went organic, I went,
I just cut everything out of my diet.
So as a bunch of issues it wasn't,
but I mean, yeah, like I cut
a lot of things out, started
working out everything.
But you know what?
I still needed medication cause it
turned out there was just um, a, uh,
it was just,
I had,
and then we figured out the headache was
linked into the ehlers Danlos Syndrome
and there some to, to clarify
everything. Some people,
when they have one autoimmune, they can
tend to cluster. So there's, that's, I, I,
I was lucky color 1 million, but that was,
that was the thing with it. But I tried,
you know, I looked into this
and I fell for all of it. Like,
so all of the pesticides are killing
you. It's the toxin. So I mean,
I understand the fear of
the people who were like,
I need to cut toxins out of my diet.
Do,
is there any foundation in truth?
Nothing.
No. Well, no pesticide. Here's the thing.
There is a little bit of truth that sells.
The lie is what? I will give
this because I, you know,
I used to work with bulk quantities of
pesticides at my last lab and that was
kind of what sealed the deal for me.
That these when they're in your
food are not gonna hurt you. Uh,
because the amount of testing we had to
go through and the amount of regulation,
I think regulation in this case it's a
good thing because it will stop a bad
pesticide, uh, for making it to market.
And I want that regulation there
because I eat the food too.
I don't want anyone's child to
ever get hurt from something that,
that me or another, like I don't work
there anymore. But you know, that,
that I had any, uh, work
and getting on the market.
I don't want to ever want that to be
the case. Um, but once upon a time,
the pesticides we had in the
market were much less targeted, uh,
to hurting the weeds and
could hurt people too.
Like arson are cynical's a sulfuric acid.
Those were early pesticides,
Paris Green, totally toxic, especially
to, uh, to the farmers and to the,
even to the farm equipment.
The stuff we have now far less toxic.
And I mean people say far less
though it's toxic. It's in, I mean,
I'm going to qualify this
answer and I mean I'm not,
I'm not qualifying it to back off from it,
but everything is toxic in
some dosage. So, yeah, exactly.
But I mean,
so roundup is one that people are really
scared of and it's one that a lot of
people know about.
There is a great graph on,
on this showing how less
toxic it is than the,
than the pesticides that
replaced because we weren't,
we didn't go from using no
pesticide to using roundup. Um,
and I know someone's going to
correct me saying it's an herbicide,
but on herbicide is pesticides the blanket
term for all things that killed, uh,
stuff in farming. Um, so before, um, uh,
before roundup,
I believe the one we used was Cyanna seen,
I could be wrong on this,
but the one we used before
roundup was in terms of the LD 50,
the lethal dose for about
50% of the population.
It was 10 times higher than roundup.
And now we barely sell any of it.
So the issue just lethal dose toxicity,
toxicity that affects your
body cause cancer. Right.
It's, I and I understand that.
So a question that, that people
are, you know, keep coming back to,
and part of the reason that people are
suspicious of it is because of its use
with a GMO and the,
these things go through hundreds
of tests and years of testing.
And because of the suspicion with roundup,
it's gone through continual testing.
Like they've tested to see if it,
uh, if it accumulates in breast milk,
it does not. Um, they've tested, tested to
see if it causes cancer, doesn't seem to.
Um,
and they've tried,
they've used it at higher doses than
it would with mice and rats. They've,
they've, they've tested in humans and
it's been on the market for 30 years.
But I mean, like it's been
in the population or it's
been used now for I believe,
25 years.
And there doesn't seem to be the only,
the only apparent increase in cancer
is because we're living longer now.
And when you have any
population that lives longer,
you have increased incidence of cancer.
Like we're not dying from polio anymore,
so we're dying from something like,
unfortunately we're not going
to live forever. So there's
toxicity issue when it comes to
roundup or when it comes to any sort of
pesticide, herbicides, herbicides
are what kills the plants, right?
Absolutely. Kills bugs or pests.
Pesticides are, it's the blanket term.
Insecticide kills bugs.
So pesticides the whole blanket term yet.
So what is, what's the most
controversial is that roundup,
roundup is controversial.
And I think the reason that it became
controversial is because people heard,
all right,
you have to genetically modify the plants
so that the roundup doesn't kill the
plant and it's this whole thing just to
make money from Monsanto and how dare
you make money. Um, and that's,
I think that was why people got mad was
because of the genetic modification.
Lincoln with roundup. Um, and it's, you
know, it's a new technology or you know,
it's,
it's one of a,
it's a newer technology and it kind of
made people a little aware of farming for
the first time.
And like I go to farming conferences
a lot of times to talk about how to
communicate agriculture. And I'll
sit down and ask farmers, you know,
what do you plant,
why are you planting it?
What do you think of Gmos you use roundup
and do you buy from people other than
do you buy from Monsanto? And do you
buy from people other than Monsanto?
And that handful of questions
will tell me. I mean, if I,
I wish I had more videos of this,
but like there's,
there's a video at some point on my site,
a with two farmers who buy from Monsanto
and buy from other companies. Uh,
and one of the reasons I asked that is
because there's a rumor on the Internet
that if you buy from Monsanto,
you can only buy from Monsanto.
Just not true. Uh, that, you know,
every genetically modified
crop is, uh, is, is, you know,
just is made to be roundup ready.
Again, not true, uh, that you know,
that people are, you
know, are being, um, that,
that people are dying of cancer
from just being around roundup.
And recently they found that one of the
reports, uh, that went through the IRC,
the cans, the place that declares things
cancerous, you know, on their, you know,
Group A, one, two, a two, a
two, a two B, um, cancer, uh,
classifications.
One of the reports was falsified
a that declared roundup cancerous.
Now we also have to fall back
by the person who is, I'm,
I have to hunt down this report.
Uh,
but the person who was trying to say
roundup is cancerous because of a little
bit of suspicion around
it because it's been,
people have kicked around that
it's causing cancer or you know,
that your spleen to turn
radioactive for you know, forever.
And it's just like a chem
trails type thing a little bit.
One of the things that people talk about
in terms of conspiracy theory and it
just, it gets put into the public sphere
so much that people start to believe it.
And here's the thing,
if I saw from evidence that
roundup had caused issues,
I would say right away, just get
rid of it, take it off the market.
And I keep on not seeing from evidence of
it, like one of the, there was a study,
there's this group moms across our moms
across America. Um, and it's, I take,
I always get my scientific information
from mom groups on the Internet. Um,
but this group,
uh,
decided to do a breastmilk study to see
a frowned up cumulated in breast milk.
And the way the study was done was they
just had women indiscriminately sending
containers of breast
milk, uh, to, to them.
And they declared like the amount of
roundup to be ridiculously high in the
breast milk. And I'm like, do they just
tell women to spray like pump bottles,
like of, uh, of roundup into
these containers and then
test it? But it turned out,
and this is just from knowing
how analytical techniques work,
like I used to design the techniques by
which we extracted a target pesticides
from a matrix and analyze them on our,
on our big overpriced, uh, machinery.
But the, uh, a woman
who was a breast milk,
a researcher out of a
University of Washington was
like, this doesn't seem right.
So she designed an experiment to,
uh,
to test if roundup was accumulating and
breast milk and she had it verified by
an outs by an independent lab, um, and it,
and they tested women specifically who
worked in agriculture and she had their
breast milk tested specifically on days
where they were spraying roundup and
there was nothing found that someone
who's not necessarily eating the food,
that someone who's working with the
food well working with roundup. Right.
And you would expect that if
it was being sprayed well,
the think about it this
way, when I'm eating it,
it's both, think about it this way.
If it's in the food supply, um,
wouldn't they be eating at as well?
I don't know. I don't know what
their diet is like if you're,
if you're getting it from people's
breast milk and those people say,
there's roundup in my breast milk and I've
been eating genetically modified crop.
Well,
the other question is if these are the
people that are following a moms across
America and their whole thing
is that roundup is the devil,
they're falsifying evidence.
I think that it was not a well controlled
experiment and it would be interesting
to see, um, to see how, um,
the experiment would come out. Um, if
the person who runs moms across America,
Zen Honeycutt would work,
would,
how it would look if zen were to look
in on every step of the process with a
Shelly Maguire, Dr Shell and
Mcguire to see that, uh, you know,
these people ate food that should
have been sprayed with roundup, uh,
and worked in the field
and then at the end, uh,
to see if their breast milk
came out with nothing yet,
don't you?
Don't you think that there'd be more
likely to be some sort of conspiratorial
collusion with people that actually work
in farms that use roundup rather than
someone who's just checking the,
their breast milk? It's like,
wouldn't you think that like if someone's
trying to prove that roundup isn't
showing up in breast milk and you've got
a bunch of people that they're living
relies on using roundup,
well, the farm workers themselves,
they'd want to be safe. Right. Mandy,
and I say that as someone who's worked
at a pesticide company and when I worked
there, I mean I was, I was
just an analytical chemist.
I'm not someone who had any investment
in keeping that company safe from being
yelled at. I want it to be safe
from the stuff I was working. Right.
Find it weird that you feel like there's
some sort of conspiracy with these moms
that are checking their breast milk,
but you don't think there might possibly
be some shenanigans involved in the
people that actually need
roundup to make a living?
It's no,
I understand what you're saying for sure.
But part of the reason why I think that
a Dr. McGuire would have conducted a
better study was number one in pa,
independently verified a number
two knows how to do collection, uh,
evidence or not ambulance,
a specimen collection accurately.
And number three monitored
and independently verified
from an outside lab.
So it's like we don't have, and when,
uh, when moms across America was asked,
uh, to show their data and how they
collected the samples, they didn't give,
they weren't willing
to, to share, uh, their,
all of their data on how
specimen collection, uh, was,
was handled was their
excuse for not sharing the,
I don't recall off the top of my
head, but they weren't like, it's,
it seems suspicious to me that they
weren't willing to disclose that. I mean,
when you're, when you do
an experiment, everything,
and I mean I used to
work under GLP standards,
which basically you throw out a glove,
you have to write it down. And that's,
that's part of the standards and how
you get, you know, a chemical into, uh,
into use in agriculture is you
really have to be careful and,
and forthcoming on how you do your work,
which is the amount of pesticides that
they found in breast milk uniform. It's,
I believe that you didn't find,
I think they were only testing for
roundup and they found there to be,
they didn't find there
to be even trace amounts,
which I was kind of surprised that I
would have expected something moms across
America stuff they found a lot.
It was a uniform.
Was everybody have like a similar amount?
No,
they found it in the amount of varied
and they were there were so high.
It was like, it was just, it was
suspicious and that's why I was like,
I don't like that was why I didn't buy it.
The other thing is they used a technique,
an analytical technique that was used
for water. And that's why I'm like,
this is not like not all techniques
you use for all work for all chemical
matrices. So that's another reason
why, you know, a different lab, uh,
was probably better equipped to handle
at one specifically that analyze this
breast milk. Um, so it's, I think
like at the other thing is, you know,
that the other lab,
the other lab kind of had a bias going
in because their whole thing is how
roundup is bad. So lab, it's like,
I just want to know if, you know,
moms are being harmed, if there's
breasts, if there's something in the,
in the breastmilk that seems
like a lab that, you know,
went in just wanting to know the other lab
went and saying, I hate roundup. So if,
you know, I would have, if, if
roundup had been found in, uh,
in the test that Dr
Mcguire's lab had done,
I would have happily accepted
those results because it, you know,
it almost wouldn't, it would have
surprised me, not in the least if,
if it had been found,
but I was kind of,
I was Kinda glad that there was nothing
there because it means that, you know,
babies aren't getting a concentrated
dose of this, uh, just because you know,
you don't want extraneous
chemicals going into the food.
So I only testing people that worked in
these farms is that, was that the idea?
I think they did.
I don't remember off the top of my head,
but I know one of the people,
one of the groups,
they did test for women on testing days,
but they go to this way.
They're not just spraying
it. They're also, you know,
possibly eating food that's been, uh,
that's had it on there. That's possibly,
it would be more interested in seeing
100% sure that these people were eating
food.
That makes sense with roundup.
And that doesn't make sense
to me that they didn't do
that. It's, I'm, you know, I,
I'd have to, I want to have a look at
the study again in myself just to be,
just to be sure of what
the other conditions were
curious about both tests have
I have a look.
Um,
we can have a quick peek a after it for
Dr Shell and Maguire breastmilk roundup
study. The whole thing
seems a little weird to me.
It's weird that one group tests high,
one, two group test. Not at all.
It's,
it is,
I'm going to say it is easy
to screw up a study using,
um, if you're not sure the parameters
you're supposed to use in an analytical,
uh,
in,
in a chemical analysis thing because you
can have interfering species that come
up with the same peaks at the same
time. Uh, so I'm, the other thing is,
like I said,
we,
the biggest thing is don't know the
collection parameters for the one that mom
across America did sign. They
won't tell us. Yeah. I mean it's,
the other thing is Dr. McGuire was
doing it through a university and she
could've been,
she could've been a lot of trouble if
she falsified a or data or done or done a
test that was purposefully misleading.
Right. So what are the pesticides?
Did you Google the pesticides that are,
yeah, both. There's a, from the put 'em
up, uh, there's a long list somewhere,
but the, uh, I had it
right here. It's on the USA
or usda.gov website. It just,
it's like a, the standards of what they
use to put stuff on and off of it. Okay.
And there are a organic standards
that allows some substances,
but where they're mostly trying to
get out synthetic substances. However,
there are also some synthetic
substances that are allowed to, yeah,
interesting.
And this is to label something organic,
right? And then there's a board
that votes on it from time to time.
If somebody wants to bring something
up and disagree that it shouldn't be on
that list.
Isn't that weird though? I mean,
most people think he say organic.
Most people think there's no pesticides.
Most people think you're
just growing plants.
Yeah. And that's, it's an, I mean
they, they saw that so well don't they?
For instance, for Mons
Pheromones, pheromones,
pheromones, pheromones. Pheromones
have long been used as effective,
nontoxic waste to confuse
insects. Hmm. Well,
that might otherwise in fest
organic crops, especially fruit.
So they put some certain
smells just freak bugs out.
Likewise,
vaccines for animals are important.
Disease Prevention tools against many
infectious diseases, blah, blah, blah.
Especially since antibiotic
therapy is prohibited in livestock.
I'm picturing an anti-vaxxer staying
away from organic produce because they
vaccinated it against bees.
Well, you could always grow
your own food, folks. You know,
and not put anything on it, but I
think large scale domestic agriculture,
if you're talking about these gigantic
fields, nothing could be less natural.
It's not normal to have
a thousand acres of corn.
It just doesn't exist in the wild.
And when you do that,
you're going to run
into a lot of problems.
Since I always go back to the argument
of nothing we're doing is natural anyway.
We're sitting in a, in an air condition
studio in, in California that we,
we'd probably be, we'd be dead
with a lot of the things that we,
we don't have that's, that's,
you know, come out food.
There's no food around here.
Where are you growing food? It's, no, it
was, no one's grown food anywhere near us.
There's, there's nothing
that we enjoy that's, that's
natural. Any more ice creams?
Not Natural. And it's God Tam.
Delicious. I'm going to get a freezer.
How do you get a freezer?
Yeah.